six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's go to
someone who's been holding for a while
and who is calling from a very very
risky area code when I go to four eight
zero it doesn't always go super well it
sometimes goes off the rails but I'm
gonna do it and I want to go to four
eight zero caller who's there David I
can my name is rod I'm from Arizona
alright and I wanted to bring up a
recent situation I've been seeing a lot
in regards to a couple of different
subjects okay the first subject regards
to the recent mass shootings have been
going on
I see I'm an X I'm an ex-army I served
in the US military for about four years
and I'm also a progressive and I've been
seeing a huge skew of conservatives
trying to basically talk down and
disrespect other people on the left in
regards to their free speech in their
opinion towards gun control and you know
what the Second Amendment means what
have you and I've also been seeing a
massive slew of people criticizing
people on the Left that are on YouTube
for example there's a gentleman I
watched him die
dusty Smith from the cult dusty he was
recently criticized by a prominent
conservative on YouTube named Barbara
Blair white and basically speaking what
is it with the Conservatives in regards
to criticizing not the ideology or the
ideals of the people in regards to an on
up painting they disagree with but
directly attacking people for using
their First Amendment right I I don't
want to I'm listening back on that tip
in to be totally fair there you're
talking about an ad hominem right which
is attacking the person rather than
their argument or their idea correct
it's not just the right that does it to
the left the left does it to the right
as well and certainly when you start
losing the facts when you start losing
on the facts you often will resort to ad
homonyms and attack you know whether
it's the credibility or intelligence or
whatever of the person making the
argument I think that what's more
interesting about that what you're
pointing out because that homonyms are
certainly nothing new it's the hypocrisy
with which someone will say
that the left is attacking the
constitutionally guaranteed Second
Amendment but then will immediately
attack that person's constitutionally
guaranteed First Amendment rights that
to me is the more interesting hypocrisy
particularly because those on the right
claim to say that this is all for the
Constitution and it's all for the Bill
of Rights and the Second Amendment well
who says that you can stop people's
First Amendment right because you don't
feel that they have the right opinion on
your second Amendment right and and so
that hypocrisy is something I'm very
concerned about my biggest issue in
regards to this is you would see people
strong conservatives like Tommy Larry
criticizing people like black lives
matter or the NFL players taking heat
which is a clear example of freedom
expression right you would see multiple
times conservatives on Fox News or
across the mean there's multiple videos
on YouTube from prominent conservative
anti sgw if there are reading on the the
parklands victim in regards to their
exposing their free speech in regards to
their opinion of gun control and you're
right I agree that the people are there
are regressives on the left that do try
to talk down or hinder people especially
University yeah but I've been just
seeing this just astounding of
disrespect toward the First Amendment
over the last years especially ever
since the 2016 election yeah there is I
want to be clear I have no problem with
someone disagreeing with kneeling during
the national anthem right like that
that's that's just a disagreement we can
all have what I have a problem with this
saying that the players should not be
allowed to kneel or they should be fired
or whatever right that's the problem I
have but we can have a debate over
whether it's a an effective form of
protest whether it's protesting the
right thing for example but that's
because I'm a supporter of the First
Amendment right exactly alright thank
you for the call really appreciate it
thank you for your Chavous as well thank
you sir you have a good day all right
you too appreciate it this episode of
the show is made possible in part by
zipper that's zpe our zipper is
designing a global decentralized
peer-to-peer alliance through which
companies can provide
secure global and diversified investment
portfolios to minimize risk
zippers initial coin offering for their
new cryptocurrency starts April 16th
zippers goal is to use smart contract
technology to provide a revolutionary
method of funding transactions between
borrowers and lenders worldwide and one
of the best potential benefits would be
zippers ability to allow people with no
credit to borrow currency through
alternative forms of verifying
creditworthiness on the zipper
blockchain if you're watching this on
YouTube look in the description for a
link to their website and links to
information about their airdrop and
bounty program this is not financial
advice and of course everyone should do
their own research before spending money
anywhere